also meine damen und herren sie werden
es wahrscheinlich in ihren familien
genauso kennen oder im freundes und
bekanntenkreis die impfpflicht spaltet
die meinungen sind kontrovers die einen
sagen so die anderen sagen so und auch
bei uns in der redaktion hierbei bild
ist das überhaupt nicht anders und
deshalb sandra wir machen mal platz
kommt es jetzt zu einem duell hier bei
uns im studio und bitte der bumper
[Musik]
bei uns im studio und bildpolitik
chefreporter peter tiede beide sehr sehr
drin im thema wieder du hast gestern
auch im bundestag philipp du hast
kommentiert bitteschön ring frei tja
dann fange ich doch mal anfangen mädels
entschlossen argumente machen dann fange
ich an also ich bin entschlossen gegen
die impfpflicht und zwar weil ich das
weil ich nicht sehe welches ziel man
damit erreichen will und zwar sagt man
ja man möchte die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems verhindern aber die
omikron wird uns nicht an den rande des
kollapses bringen womöglich andere
varianten aber gegen die haben wir gar
keine impfstoffe also wir müssten auf
vorrat gegen eine variante an impfen die
wir noch nicht kennen und das argument
funktioniert nicht also ich bin nicht
für eine generelle sofort umzusetzen sie
endlich ich bin aber dafür dass der
staat alles vorbereitet für den fall
dass wir wieder in eine lage geraten wo
das gesundheitssystem gefährdet ist
darauf muss man vorbereitet sein auch
mit gesetzen die kann man auch auf
vorrat machen und wenn dann die
richtigen hürden davor gestellt sind
dann bin ich dafür dass der staat eine
impfpflicht durchführt weil die
impfpflicht dann für mich der kleinere
eingriff griff ist gegenüber monatelang
wochen lang ganz viele einschränkungen
zu machen für alle bürger dann bin ich
eher dafür dann zu sagen aber wirklich
wirklich wenn die hohe hürde
überschritten ist dass das
gesundheitssystem in gefahr ist wie ein
impfstoff haben der taugt also ein
wirksames mittel haben und kein anderes
mittel mehr zur verfügung steht dass er
dann vorbereitet sind mit einer
impfpflicht die dann kurzfristig
umgesetzt werden kann ich bin nicht
dafür dass wir vorrat sagen wir müssen
uns jetzt zehn jahre lang impfen lassen
aber der staat hat vorzüge vorbereitet
zu sein darauf dass das was wir jetzt
erlebt haben nicht noch einmal passiert
und dass die impfpflicht an der kleinere
eingriff für mich als zu sagen wir
schicken die kinder wieder alle nach
hause wir haben homeschooling wir haben
das ganze chaos wieder und dann lieber
eine impfpflicht ist für mich sehr
kleinem aufwand aber ich sehe gar nicht
dass wir diese alternative haben
entweder impfpflicht oder lockdown ich
glaube wenn es uns darum geht die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems zu
verhindern ja dann bereiten wir doch das
gesundheitssystem vor das war ja auch
schon vor caroline große heute denn die
flieger her nie wozu die intensivpflege
daher an dem wo willst du die anderen
pflegeheimen und so die ärzte her die
dann die aufgaben dann noch erledigen
sollen wir sehen das jetzt ja schon dass
wir ein problem haben nicht weil wir zu
viele patienten haben sondern weil so
viele leute jetzt schon in quarantäne
sind und du kriegst du kannst du die
pflege an dich backen du kannst du die
ärzte auch nicht packen sie sind einfach
nicht da oder gar nicht mehr da aber
versucht der staat denn überhaupt die
diesen menschen ja
ich habe diese versuche ehrlich gesagt
nicht ausreichend gesehen wir sind als
die leute rekrutieren weil sie auf der
straße nicht vorhanden ist schlicht und
ergreifend physischen nicht da und dann
musst du anders vorbereitet und wir
haben auch keine klempner wir haben auch
keine gas wasserinstallateur wir haben
ganz viele leute nicht einfach weil die
bevölkerungspyramide so steht wir haben
die alte als das der junge haben und sie
wachsen einfach nicht nach polizisten
wachsen auch nicht auf den bäumen und
pfleger auch nicht und mein argument ist
ja nicht wir müssen alle jetzt sofort
impfen wir müssen uns dreimal mehr
impfen lassen sondern wirklich zu sagen
wir müssen vorbereitet sein es muss ein
gesetz auf vorrat da sein das ist auch
wirklich gut und die debatte gestern die
die bundestagwahl vereine der sachlichen
die ich je erlebt habe weil es wirklich
eine gewissensfrage sind ich hab's ich
sehe auch allein wende ich sehe alle
einwände kommt für mich aber dann zu dem
schluss dann ist die impfpflicht flügen
noch ein alter ein kam kann man auch
machen 40 50 da wo die großen probleme
anfangen also die jahrgänge die dann
quasi die intensivstation verstopfen
dafür wird die altersgrenze ein und ich
sehe alle verfassungsrechtlichen
bedenken aber wenn es keine andere
möglichkeit gibt kein scharfes schwert
mehr gibt als eine impfpflicht dann bin
ich dafür dass der staat darauf
vorbereitet ist für mich macht sich der
staat einfach einen schlanken fuß wir
sind jetzt seit zwei jahren in der
pandemie wir haben gesehen dass pfleger
kündigen oder ihre arbeitszeit
reduzieren auch weil sie nicht genug
kunden nicht gut genug bezahlt sind weil
zu wenig leute eine weit so wenig leute
geimpft sind und dadurch zu viele leute
einfach im krankenhaus sind ja ehrlich
gesagt hatten wir auch schon bevor es
überhaupt einen impfstoff gab probleme
und auch schon vor corona hatten wir
probleme und wenn wir jetzt sehen dass
das dass das nadelöhr ist sagt das dass
die intensivstation das große problem
sind das zu lösen mussten dann erwarte
ich vom staat dass er alles dafür tut um
mehr pflege um mehr ärzte zu rekrutieren
auch aus anderen ländern zu holen und
vor allem diese menschen die bei uns
sind dafür zu sorgen dass sie anständig
bezahlt werden und nicht kündigen oder
ihre arbeitszeiten reduziert dann und
das tut der meinung mein land wäre die
alternative wir vergolden den
pflegeberuf wir schauen anderen ländern
der ärzte die sie vielleicht selber
brauchen und wir könnten auch noch die
pfleger mit dazu dass in deren betten
ungepflegt und wir haben hier tausende
zusätzliche intensivbetten angeschafft
und die betten sind ja nicht das problem
die besonders international ja aber
alles ist kannst du nicht packen wir
haben auch keine polizisten wir haben
auch keine maurer wir haben auch keine
klempner wir haben auch keine leute die
bei rewe noch die regale einräumen weil
sie einfach physisch nicht vorhanden
sind wir haben auch in der gastronomie
fielen vier menschen wir haben schlicht
und ergreifend eine verkehrt herum
stehen der bevölkerungspyramide bei uns
steht der weihnachtsbaum einfach auf den
kopf so und du kannst du die leute nicht
packen du kannst ihn das geld hinterher
werfen wie du irgendwie willst du wirst
keine intensivpfleger ging das ist ja
jetzt kein beruf du kannst du die vom
apfel flüge um schulen sondern das ist
ein richtiger ordentlicher beruft die
musst du auch erlernen und dann findest
du das wirklich in ordnung dass der
staat menschen die vielleicht angst
haben die unsicher sind die auch völlig
ich finde das legitim auch mal kein
vertrauen zu haben sie unsicher zu sein
dass der mensch das der stadt diese
menschen allesamt nicht zwingend mit
physischer gewalt aber doch den druck so
weit erhöht dass sie sich impfen lassen
müssen dass mit der roten ampel anhalten
auch farben blinde müssen fortbestehen
der schlusssatz
ich danke euch ganz herzlich und wir
sehen ja das was er gestern im parlament
auch erlebt haben eine orientierungs
debatte wir suchen alle momentan noch
nach orientierung und die einen sagen so
die anderen sagen so aber war ich total
gut dass wir beide argumente
ausgetauscht haben vielen dank für die
tiere und vielen dank peter thiede